before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
I would say this is where the plot
thickens but I think this might be the
point where the plot turns to concrete
but maybe that's the next one
take two Doctor Who reviews continue and
I move forward in my re-watch of Doctor
Who flux and
I'm trying something a little different
with this one
because my opinion of the Halloween
apocalypse basically reaffirmed
that yes it was as bad as I remember
possibly even slightly worse my re-watch
of War of the sontarens
told me that the one I remembered as the
good one had a lot of problems with it I
kind of Forgotten or was more forgiving
of and the stuff that was good about it
doesn't quite hold up the same on a
re-watch
so
knowing that I don't feel great about
the remaining episodes of this I'm
coming into this
deliberately trying to be as positive as
I can
because otherwise this is going to be a
miserable slog for you for me
for all of us
so did my going into Once Upon Time the
point at which I basically gave up on
flux when it first aired
re-watching that with that mindset did
it help
yeah actually a bit I'm not sure what
helped uh Halloween apocalypse to be
clear because that one was just it's
just such a cramp mess even if I'm
looking for the good it's sharing space
with so much other stuff that it's just
too dang much but this one
there's more good here than I remembered
there being
I still don't really like I'm not
turning around in my overall assessment
of the episode I don't think that's
going to happen with any of these if
we're being honest
um for the remainder of this series but
I do think that there is something to be
said for
knowing how the pieces fit together well
more or less because
part of the thing with watching it the
very first time was that this episode in
particular
felt like it should have been laying the
Firm Foundation for where we were going
like Halloween apocalypse introduced
nearly every friggin plot thread and
just dumped them on us War of the
santarans was more focused but it was
because it largely had to deal with the
plot that didn't have to do with most of
the rest of the flux and then the stuff
that had to do with flux wasn't really
that much better and this episode when
watching it for the first time felt like
what should have been like a firming up
and a solidifying of what the main
thrust of flux was and it just felt like
a mess
on first viewing because I'm like if
you're trying to to start solidifying
what you're doing for me it's not
working but now having come back to it
watching it again and having seen the
whole thing and knowing where it's
going-ish
this has more good
to it than I gave it credit for at the
time or in my memory if I'm being honest
what kind of good is there well
honestly the dream logic and the
off-putting nature of the way the sort
of dream sequences are done
whether it be you know the doctor who
gets the primary focus being suddenly in
her own past occupying we find out a
little bit into the episode The Fugitive
doctor's body but also like being like
wait this isn't right I shouldn't be
here and that sort of fading in and out
of a dream understanding where like this
isn't how it's supposed to be but also
you kind of also know what the rules are
now that you're here that's sort of way
that your brain eases you into a dream
state and a narrative that does not make
sense but it's gonna make sense for now
and the doctor sort of phasing in and
out of that mindset of wait a minute and
also oh yeah right and it also does it
very well with Dan I think especially
with the way that the scene flows with
him and die and you know they're in the
daylight Suddenly It's night and he you
can tell he has like a quick second of
what and then like okay yeah no no yeah
of course it's night it reminded me his
section especially remind to me a little
bit of Donna
um in the in the computer when Donna
Noble was saved in the two-parter set in
the library with her talking about wait
how did we get here and then like
the the machine kind of backfilling in
the jump that just happened you've done
so much in seven years
sometimes it was more like 70.
well she sometimes it feels like no time
at all it reminded me a little bit of
that in a good way not in a derivative
way but in a evoking a similar overall
field that is just meant to put you off
a little bit Yaz is used largely to
introduce the Weeping Angels into this
but it's pretty well done as far as that
goes
um you know I would argue that the
Weeping Angels into the overall story
that flux is supposedly telling their
presence doesn't really help that story
very much and probably actively
distracts from it in the end but if I
take that as a given and just deal with
the fact that they're here
this is a decent introduction to to them
and the way like it she keeps seeing it
in the mirror initially and then looking
back and it's gone in addition to the
stuff like the the other cop in the car
with her looking like the doctor and
then not and that whole dream sort of
feel to those segments in general
is really well done I like anything that
can properly capture that
wait a minute wait but wait feeling of
knowing you're in a dream but also not
fully having a complete grasp and not
being 100 certain that that's what's
going on and it captures that feeling
really well and I'd kind of forgotten it
had done that and uh just a quick note
for the pendants in the audience yes I
am aware this is not actually a dream
for any of them they're back in their
own timeline but their timeline is
messed up but dreamlike is the feel that
it goes for that's what I'm talking
about don't at me vendors bits with sort
of going through his own backstory are
are a little bit weaker in terms of
capturing that feel but it's also
genuinely filling in backfill for him
that we don't know because we don't
really know this guy yet and since it
has to strike the balance of giving us
more actual information on him that was
probably the right call to make this
also gives us the introduction of the
grand serpent who I would argue is both
one more villain than we need and also
still probably one of the more effective
villains that is present and I say that
as someone who doesn't think sworn
manager are terrible they just don't
fully work the grand serpent like right
from his first introduction when you
first see I'm I mean just the fact that
his name's the grand serpent honestly
but just when you're in the room with
him and he's just talking calmly and you
know vendor's gonna be uh you know
watching him be his bodyguard or or what
have you and Linda just says something
offhandedly in the grand Sermon Just
goes silent just turns and looks at him
and just that quiet sense of like oh
geez I don't even know why that was the
wrong thing to say but holy crap am I in
trouble now he captures that feeling
really really well and I remember from
scenes later in flux like he's good for
this
in terms of the overall narrative again
like a lot of stuff going on in Flex I
don't know why he's here what well let
me back up I get why he's here in
vendor's backstory he's actually kind of
core to it I don't remember why he shows
up later
and like the very nature of the flux
kind of gets thrown off a little bit in
this because when it was depicted before
it really didn't seem like it was just
flat out destroying stuff
but we opened with Belle
and Bell is uh
she's sort of moving yeah a lot of plans
destroy but a lot of them are also still
there like destroyed buildings but like
wait why is anything left I thought
wasn't the nature of this thing like
completely wipe out everything and I
guess like it still can kind of work but
it's one of the many things that doesn't
get explained particularly well because
even the nature of what the flux is and
exactly what it does on impact is never
made completely clear so it struck me
weird at the time and also now on the
rewatch strikes me as odd that there is
as much left as there is at all
and also the introduction of bell it
jumps in right on her and I don't know
why they play so coy with the fact that
she's connected to vendor because they
don't reveal that towards the bat until
towards the back end of the episode I
don't know why that's held back because
first of all as a Twist quote unquote it
holds no real relevance and no real
meaning but at the same time holding
back that information and making it
unclear how she connects to what else is
going on makes it harder to latch onto
her story and to care because you're
like I don't know this person and I
don't know how they connect to this I
don't know why you're showing me this
and it's really hard to do that and get
the audience to invest
but on a re-watch that's not as much of
a problem because I know what her
connection is so I was able to
appreciate her actual story in and of
itself a little bit more and it's not
too bad I still think it is actually a
problem that they don't reveal her
connection to vendor much sooner than
they did I think it's nothing but a
detriment to the narrative to hold that
back for as long as they do in this
episode but knowing that does help quite
a bit so we get a little bit more sort
of info about passenger sort of um but
we also don't know entirely what's going
on with that uh we get the
reintroduction of tech taehyun who has
not yet identified as such but will be
and this idea that the flux was caused
on purpose because of the doctor
and
there's some stuff that's
set about Swarm at Azure that I I really
couldn't fully parse it
I couldn't tell if tectane was implying
that
them getting loose was
part of the flux or like was necessary
for the flux to happen or they were
taking advantage of the flux like
it's mentioned it's part of it like it's
it's made very unclear like there are so
many antagonistic forces in this
and how they connect to each other or to
the flux is very thin and sometimes
non-existent it's
it it's made all the weirder that this
thing was called flux like yes a lot of
stuff is everything's kicked off by that
event but not everything ties into it
really so it's weird
and another thing from Belle's story is
we see we get and this comes up in Dan's
story as well as like we get these sort
of it's not a good effect it actually
reminds me a lot of the kind of effects
that were done in the third doctor's era
but these sort of blue little Mite
things that like wipe things out and
said at one point that they're wiping
out anomalies I'm about to say something
that's going to be really weird for
anyone who knows this Channel and knows
things that I've said including not too
long ago
uh why aren't they just the Reapers then
now I understand
I don't like the Reapers I don't really
like the episode Father's Day all that
much in the first place and I really
don't like the Reapers I put them on my
list of worst one-off villains
but if you're gonna have something that
is effectively doing the exact same
thing
why not just make use of the thing that
already exists
instead of the I mean it might have been
budgetary I imagine this is probably
cheaper to render than trying to update
the look of the Reapers to Modern
expectations but
like it's very strange to me because
it's doing the literal exact same thing
as described
so
just use the thing that's already
established I mean my actual argument
would be maybe don't bother with this
stuff at all it doesn't actually seem to
matter or do much or impact anything
it's just there it's another thing
that's just there but like if you're
gonna have it like reuse stuff recycle
it's good for the environment I do
appreciate that we get some more Joe
Martin as The Fugitive doctor not
because she gets a ton to do but just
because I really like her as the doctor
so any additional time we get with her I
appreciate they really severely
underutilized her
like it's it's almost criminal how
underused she is over the course of this
but we get a little more time with her I
appreciate that and with the sort of
flashbacky stuff that we get with her we
do get a clear connection between the
ravagers that swarming Azure and the
Mori which I again is a concept I don't
like
but that still doesn't really connect
them to the flux
so again
how why huh
this does still suffer
from uh as a microcosm of a lot of the
problems with the story overall there's
too many threads they don't properly
connect and there isn't time to clarify
what's here because too much stuff is
taking up space
so that is what's going on with this
episode as it is going on with the whole
thing but as I said at the beginning
there's more good here than I thought
there's some well done tension with the
angel in Yaz there's just a good dream
like uh sense to the earlier ends of it
this actually now that we're actually
getting time with vendor he's been plot
important already and they really should
have established him before doing any of
that but now that we are getting
background on him
it's well conveyed you get a good strong
sense of his moral Center as a character
about what it was he was prepared to put
his neck on the line for and it tells
you a lot about him it's not bad
storytelling at all it's a little bit
like how I came to appreciate how good
Dan's introduction was in Halloween
apocalypse like
that's a lot better handled than I was
expecting based on my memory of this I
kind of feel the same about vendor's
backstory I think the placement of when
we learn it maybe isn't where it should
be but what we actually learn and also
seeing his reaction for like being this
semi-dream state of being like oh maybe
relive this bit
again it tells you a lot about him in an
interesting
um engaging way
there is good actually quite a bit more
good in this than I remembered
still kind of a mess and the
Cliffhangers can I okay look I don't
like Cliffhangers
broadly speaking I just don't
it my preferred version of a cliffhanger
is debatably not a cliffhanger at all I
don't really like the oh and here's the
sudden threat I like a more of a grander
sense like here's the way I tend to put
it I don't find it particularly engaging
if you have the hero dangling off a
cliff at the end of an episode I know
they're not gonna fall off that cliff
they're not it's got to be dealt within
the first 20 seconds of the next episode
but you want to end an episode with them
pulling themselves up off that Cliff so
they're no longer dangling but then they
look out and they see
the Army The Fortress the castle or
whatever it is they're gonna have to try
and deal with and you give a sense of
the size of the scope of that problem
that's a cliffhanger-ish thing that can
work for me but this is very much the
let's just and like this is very him
physicist out of nowhere suddenly ah the
Angel's on the Tardis ha
like I know the Angels got established
already and yaz's thing so it's like
it's not a complete diabolous ex machina
they do get established we know they're
around and evolved but like this does
just happen suddenly to give us a
cliffhanger
I and yeah it's it's it's a thing I
don't enjoy in general and I don't like
it here
but Once Upon Time
quite a bit better than I remembered it
without still actually being good
but
credit where credit's due a lot more
good in this than I remembered
so
have you ever watched this episode
lately whatever you thought about it
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it patreon pays the
bills and enables me to do this as my
living even if you can't help me out
that way like share subscribe those are
also of great assistance there's links
to other stuff that I do other platforms
that I'm that I'm at merch my books that
I've written
etc etc all down in the description but
um
don't worry too much about it
what I really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you're valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
massive thanks to my patreon supporters
and in particular I want to thank Robin
Moore Zubin look full up to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime Ruth
Oliver B solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen the
oatha Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
for Nabi likes the poodle Robin Powell
Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam RDL
Taylor David Hall Shayla Gourley and
Rosalind Bennett thanks for your support
you can get your name in the credits too
if you feel like hearing me possibly
struggle with it for several times
before getting it right
[Music]